I know you're very interested in this
topic because it's going to work with
you and thank the organizers for
inviting me to this wonderful workshop
so the title of the talk is removal
limits for Kaiser graphs and product
graphs or the Swiss cheese phenomenon
which I will describe shortly and here's
here's a table that gives some insight
or background about about what I'm going
to talk about it has three columns first
two columns relate to graphs in the
third is a hyper graph and the first
column is where the theorem sound most
interesting to combina tourists when
they're stated the second column is
where we really work when we think about
this it's it's where we try to do the
proofs and the third column is the one
that gave us inspiration so I'll explain
what are these three khans
first column is the crazy graph with
parameters N and n over three but one
third is just an arbitrary choice you
can put there alpha and for any fixed
alpha it's a bird the vertices of this
graph are all subsets of n of size n
over three so you take all subsets these
are other vertices and two are connected
by an edge a B if they're disjoint okay
so an independent set in this graph it's
a bunch of vertices it's a bunch of sets
which every two intersect it's an
intersecting family so independent sets
in this graph are intersecting families
and the degree in this graph if you fix
a set how many disjoint sets do you have
it's 2/3 n choose and over 3 which is
much smaller than n choose n over 3 so
this is a sparse graph ok and one remark
since we're going to use analysis and we
do this based on product graphs the way
we actually deduce theorems about this
it's very similar to a graph you take
the two-point graph with a loop on 0 and
you endow it with a measure 2/3 on 0 and
1/3
and then you take its tensor with itself
n times so that that gives you a
creation graph on all subsets of n but
the measure is concentrated near the
sets of size n over 3 and you can by
analyzing what happens on this product
graph you can deduce a lot of things
that happen in this on one layer okay
that's it so you put a measure I'm here
I'm going to talk throughout to talk
about sizes of sets but you you can put
weights on the vertices and then study
the measure of sets you get a small set
or a large that won't mean number of
vertices but it's matter so if you just
put the measure 2/3 on 0 and third on 1
and then you take the product measure so
the measure of a vector is a third race
to the number of ones times 2/3 raised
the number of zeros and then that
measure is concentrated near the vectors
that have approximately 1/3
they ain't over three ones so so the
product is with a well let's look at the
this it will make it easier to explain
the product whatever the product is I'll
tell you for a second it gives you the
class of graph it it means that for two
sets to be neighbors on the graph they
have to be disjoint
okay but the product is that in every
coordinate you have to be a neighbor in
the base graph so the second graph is
you take the triangle and raise it to
the nth power so the vertices of the
triangle are 0 1 2 oops I'm missing in
in here so the vertices of the big graph
are all trinity strings of length N and
taken a string of length n of 0 and 2 so
have 3 to the N vertices and 2 vertices
are connected by an edge if they differ
in every coordinate which means from the
base graph their neighbors 0 is the
neighbor 1 and 2 but not of itself so
two vertices are neighbors this is very
different from the Hamming graph it's
the opposite of the Hamming graph two
vertices are neighbors if they differ in
every coordinate so what's an
independent set here it's a bun
vertices such that every two of them
agree on some coordinate and the
canonical example is just fix all
vectors whose seventeenth coordinate is
2 or whose 30th coordinate is 0 so those
all agree on some coordinate hence they
don't span in the edges that's an
independent set and here the degree well
if you fix the vector and you have to
change every coordinate you have two
choices for a record Nate the degree is
2 3 which is little over 3 3 so this is
also a sparse graph the third a column
is a hyper graph its vertices are the
edges of the complete graph take fix and
end points and look at the pair's these
are the vertices of the hypergate
and the edges the edges of the hyper
graph are triangles take any three pairs
which form a triangle a B BC a C so the
number of vertices is order of N squared
but if you fix two points they only
belong to n minus 2 triangles so here
too it's a very sparse hyper graph the
degree is only n minus 2 whereas it
could potentially have been order N
squared so all these 3 creatures are
very sparse now let's talk about in all
these cases it's easy to describe the
maximal independent set but there's also
stability phenomenon so explain what
that is now let's start from in this
column a maximal triangle free graph has
long tails theorem from 1907 or 2007
which it's just a special case of
torrance theorem which was proved more
than 20 years later if you have a graph
with no triangles it has its most N
squared over 4 edges or and over to
ceiling times and over to floor edges so
that describes what the maximal triangle
free graphs are how many vertices you
can take in this hyper graph without
spanning an edge but there are a lot of
stability results and I couldn't even
cite all the different proofs that if
you have a graph which is a triangle
free and has almost N squared over 4
edges it
means that it's very close to being
bipartite you can make it bipartite by
very small changes in the in this graph
the maximal independent sets are what I
described before fix the coordinate and
take all vectors that I have that
coordinate equal to your choice that's
one third you have independent sets of
size one third and once again there's a
paper from 2004 along Denorfia to the
cove where we prove stability if you
have an independent set of size 1/3
minus epsilon and it has to be close in
structure to a real maximal set the only
way a maximal independent set only way
you can get a really big close to a
maximal independent set is taking a
maximal independent set then playing
around with it a bit and for
intersecting families so if you fix K
and you want to take as many case sets
subsets of n and get an intersecting
family its K is less than n over 2 then
the air - Colorado theorem says the best
you can do is fix one point take all
subsets that contain it and here -
there's stability so I should write here
Hilton Millner also but these are
stronger quantitatively so a paper of
mind from 2008 using Fourier analysis
and a paper of key version mu by E from
2010 show once again stability if you
have an intersecting family of sizes
close to n minus 1 choose K minus 1 but
here definition of closed matters then
it's closed and structured to being an
intersecting family O 2 being maximal in
the second example ok now ok so if you
look for example at this graph we
understand the maximal independent set
what about is there any hope of
describing all independent set
well one thing you can do is take so
let's call the maximal independent sets
of dictators because you fix a
coordinate and fix the value on that
coordinate well one thing you could do
is take a subset of a dictator of course
that's one thing you could do and but
another thing you could do is instead
with the dictator take a Hunta so take
all vectors who on the first three
coordinates have at least two zeroes
okay so that's cool because it depends
only on three coordinates
that's not contained in a dictator but
any two such vectors share some
coordinate in which there is zero right
if you have twelve to three zeroes and
two out of three zeroes they have to
intersect so you can get the dependent
sets here by taking giunta's and it
turns out paper demo free cotton rageth
from 2008 but essentially that's the
only thing you can do you can you take
take a hunter that gives you an
independent set then you essentially but
I'll describe this in greater detail you
know in a second then you can take a
subset of the hunter subsets of an
independent set is still and then you
can add a little tiny little bit of
noise add a few vertices outside and
remove their neighbors that's
essentially the only thing you can do
and this is true also in the glazier
graph if you have an intersecting family
it's essentially contained in an
intersecting family which is determined
by a small number of elements this is
paper of Dumoulin myself where for some
range of parameters it follows
immediately from bfr and for smaller
it's for any closer graph even when the
size of the sets is fixed or a little
over but for fixed if for fixed size it
falls from DFR now here describing in
the pen sets is understanding all
triangle free graphs so air displacement
android shield proves it almost all
triangle free graphs are bipartite but i
think if you if you use the same already
regularity lemma I'm not going to say
anything about it now then you can
really understand really understand
triangle three graphs take a similarity
partitioning and and the the super
partition is triangle free and and
that's so your graph was close to
something like that so that really
explains all triangle three graphs now
know well it is it depends on what in
what way or counting if if you're
interested now if you're interested in
dense graphs then almost all the way to
get the triangle free graphs is to take
a fixed triangle free graph and just
blow this off add whatever you want
between this and add epsilon and squared
edges that's the only thing you can do
so in spirit it's similar to what I
described before I agree that if you
want to understand sparse triangle free
graphs and that's that's a whole
different game that's definitely
different okay now we're coming did they
stop we're talking about removal Emma's
so this is this is our starting point
that I said that this column gives us
the inspiration so the celebrated
rucious Eveready theorem from 1978 it's
a triangle removal lemma from graphs so
here is what it says for every epsilon
you have a delta such that if your graph
spans less than Delta n cubed triangles
so if it you you you have you take a
bunch of edges it's just a sub graph of
the complete graph and that and that
graph has very few triangles it means
that you can remove very few edges and
get the triangle free graph okay now I
mean the first hundred times I've looked
at this statement I had to look at it at
a long time to understand whether it's
trivial or not and eventually I decided
that it isn't so the easiest way to
convince you that it isn't trivial is
that it implies roth's theorem okay so
it implies that any dense a subset of
integers has a three term arithmetic
aggression but that's that's it easily
implies that the but that's a meta
argument but here okay and I'll try to
convince you in a second that it's an
interesting statement and for so the
dependence that Russia and some already
got between Delta and epsilon was that a
tower of height 1 over epsilon to the
fifth and so horribl dependence and it's
very very very far from the lower bound
which comes from barons construction and
for many many years it was it was
considered a major open problem to
improve this dependence and 2011 Fox
improved this dramatically from a tower
of size poly epsilon to the tower of
size low of 1 over epsilon and our proof
essentially was inspired by Fox's proof
and and I'll explain about that a bit
more in a second and it's nice because
this proof is really it's it's quite
accessible something you can teach in a
graduate class will take an hour to
present the proof it's really really
nice and and and you can understand but
it was considered a big deal it appeared
in the annals of mathematics and it's
really it's one of those proofs that it
may be hard to find but in retrospective
so how come we didn't think of it before
no yet but there may be nice too the gap
is still huge ok now what a whatever the
removal that so this says if you have
few edges in your hyper graph you take a
bunch of graph edges which means a bunch
of vertices in your hyper graph to that
bunch of vertices spans few edges in the
hyper graph means that you move a small
number of vertices and remain with an
independent set in your hyper graph and
what we prove is one level down the same
thing in graphs for this graph and this
graph and many other product graphs I'm
not going to classify them for you now
the following holds for every epsilon
there exist a delta
if you take a subset of the vertices
that spans a sparse graph a sparse graph
with relate a compared to the host graph
which was supposed to begin with so it
spans only Delta proportion of the edges
in your host graph then you can remove a
small number of vertices compare a small
percentage of the number of vertices in
the host graph and remain with the truly
independent set now why do they call
this the swiss-cheese phenomenon
you have your graph is like a a hunk of
Swiss cheese it's full of holes in this
hyper graph you have many many bunches
of edges with span no triangles in this
graph in these graphs you have many
bunches of vertices I mean a constant
proportion of vertices that span no
edges you have these huge independent
sets and now I challenge you I say can
you take a hunk of this cheese that
suggests before the topic called it an
induced sub cheese so you should have to
take a bunch of cheese which is very
very where the density is very very low
which is very very sparse you don't the
only way to do that is just to take a
hole and take a little bit of extra
cheese so if you give me a bunch of
cheese that spans very very little
cheese I know what you've done I just
remove some of the cheese and you just
took one of those bubbles and that's the
same thing in these graphs the only way
to get the sparse graph is to take a
large independent set and add a little
bit to it and the reason this is so it's
so delicate if I add here a little bit
of a little bit of edges in in my really
small number of edges in these
independent sets so take these graphs
and add a random matching which would
increase the degree from 2 to the N 2 to
3 n plus 1 then then this would already
be totally false because what was before
an independent set would now span V so I
have an independent set which is 1/3 of
the vertices it spends very few edges
only those that happen
to fall in from the random matching so
it would be order of n edges really
really few edges but if I want to make
it independent I'd have to move one
vertex from each edge and in the
matching so this property is very very
sensitive if you change the graph even
slightly those away which is one
indication for example that trying to
prove these things by algebraic or
spectral techniques may be hard up to
impossible because adding a matching
hardly changes the spectrum of the graph
you you really don't see it in the
spectrum of the graph but the changes
this property completely ok so what time
did I started it 42 minutes ok good so
33 minutes 443 okay well i'll try to aim
for 33 I'll pay you later okay so so
right now where did I like this theorem
a lot but main motivation to prove this
theorem was to strengthen a theorem of
ours so let me let me state the DFR the
contrapositive says that a if you have
to remove a lot of vertices to become
independent and independent set then you
spend a lot of edges so any graph which
is far from being triangle free in edges
contains a lot of triangles no in square
triangles is nothing that if you have so
for example if you have a graph where
every edge is contained in a single
triangle so we have very few triangles
that that graph must be sparse because
okay so that that's one of the nice
applications of this that's for example
a nice step in the proof of Rothstein if
you want to use this that's one of the
ways to anyhow so let's go back to the
fr and let me state a give you a
statement so we're back in this graph
where the vertices are treading vectors
of length N and 2 are adjacent if they
differ in every coordinate so the
following holes and
okay so for for every Delta there exist
some J which is going to be the size of
my hunter such that for every
independent set I there exists a set J
such that the following hole so first of
all J is a little J kunta so j j is a
bunch of vertices where the admittance a
test to this set depends only on fit on
J vertices so Jake would be 1,000 then a
you give me a vector I look I have a
fixed window of 1000 coordinates I look
at that window and I tell you whether
your vectors in J in big J or not
secondly of course well we want to say
that J captures I so if you take I and
remove J then this is less than epsilon
of the total number of vertices in the
graph
I could write here 3 2 then but I want
to keep the generality the sphere should
apply also for this graph well as I said
that this this is trivial why is it
reveal you can take J to be everything
everything depends on 0 coordinates and
everything contains anything so this
would be trivial so I'd also like to say
that J really explains why eyes an
independent set I'd like to say that J
itself is an independent set so I'm
writing J is an independent set well
when we prove this in 2008 I we wish
this was true but this isn't what we
proved we proved the J's almost an
independent set meaning that J spans
order of Jays very sparse okay so here's
the picture this is our whole graph
here's the independent set I and J
almost captures I maybe there's some
small part of I that J does not capture
and J almost explains why I think the
pay is an independent set J is almost
independent itself but all we could
prove is the J sparse now this is
annoying and we wanted to get rid of
this we wanted to remove this and we
observed that you can remove this with a
removal lemma that's not why it's called
a removal Emma but removal lemma if I
had a removal lemma that I could make J
is now sparse by removing a little more
of J but let's say part of what I'm
removing could belong to I then I get
the truly independent set and I get rid
of this so if I have the removal level
plus the weak version of the DF are like
I can call my own fear my own theorems
weak like I can tell anti-semitic jokes
but I don't want other members of the
audience to call this a weak theorem so
you take the a weak theorem and the
removal lemma and together you get the
strong link version which is what's
written here and so that was our
motivation for the removal Emma so how
much of it is the hypothesis and what's
the conclusion
okay so you have you have an independent
set
yeah l was removed it's a removal Emma
you have an independence where is
process now you have an independent set
I want to say the reason it's
independent is essentially contained in
a hunter and that hunter is an
independent said that that hunt explains
why so if your family was an
intersecting family it's contained in
all vectors where you have two out of
three of the first coordinates which are
zero I want that to be the explanation
so I fell we could find a hunter which
almost contains your family and that
what almost explains why it's
independent because that hunter spends
very few edges it it was sparse but I
wanted to totally explain I wanted that
hunter to be really independent but now
we know that if this hunter spans very
few edges by the removal Emmett can be
fixed I can remove another little part
of the hunter and now and now I have a
truly yeah so I I'm removing a tiny part
of everything is measured a with respect
to the whole the size of the graph so
everything I am i when I say I'm I'm
only moving an epsilon proportion of the
vertices left on proportion of the
vertices of the whole graph yes excuse
me
no it is because if J depends on J a
coordinates I'm going to apply this
theorem and 0 1 2 to the J okay so what
is the hunter hunter if you take J
coordinates it basically breaks my space
into 3 to the J parts where these parts
capture most of my graph but now I look
at that graph and I remove a small
proportion of those parts okay and since
all parts of the same size removing an
epsilon proportion of those parts means
removing an epsilon proportion but
that's an excellent question that shows
that you're following the time
no no no everyone else buys my lies and
you you caught me I I sort of said oh no
that's correct
now it's correct this is a this is a
theorem without almost and that this
should be Delta there is no epsilon in
the statement of the theorem okay
exponential something like that right
I think it's exponential no no no no
okay okay let's say in the in the week
therefore it depends exponentially in
this even polynomial okay
do you know ancient cow but I'll say in
a second we get the tower I know an
amusing thing is a so I want to explain
how we prove the removal Emma we use we
use the week VFR to prove the removal in
so it's it was not only the motivation
for proving the removal Emma it's also
what we need to prove it now few remarks
yeah okay it implies the strong so it
can be so some remarks let's see so the
first remark is something about related
work these triangle removal Emma's were
proved also in
you can look in an algebraic setting
take the group 0 1 to the end and then
finally triangles being X Y and Zed such
that X plus y equals that and there a
green proved been green prove the
triangle removal Emma and recently we're
Hitomi and Sukhdev until siani they
improved Green's tower from polynomial
height to logarithmic height in a manner
that's similar to how fox and improve
the rucious m already bound then just
this is a side remark that if their
triangle removal limits in four groups
in algebraic settings some other amounts
so about the techniques we used here so
I already said that a algebraic seems to
not work it seems to me that it can't
work because this property is so
sensitive you you change the graph a
little bit in the spectra doesn't change
but the the spectrum doesn't change but
the property trying to prove changes
dramatically and the second thing since
it remind us of the triangle removal
Emma
we thought maybe regularity but
regularity seems not to work also and
the thing is that these graphs are
supremely non regular risible so there's
their sparse but there's a regularity
theorem for sparse graphs also but these
graphs cannot be regularized no matter
how small a chunk you take if you take
two sets
there's always big the Swiss cheese
always will leaves us big bubbles
between those sets so you if you want to
set where the density is is preserved on
all the subsets those sets have to be
really exponentially small so you can't
regularize this graph so regularity
seems
not too not not a beedi so but Thurber
Martha would say something about the
dependence between epsilon epsilon and
Delta so in all our examples we try to
find the worst possible dependence the
dependence we found this polynomial
whereas what we can prove is a tower of
height a log 1 over Epsilon so ever it's
it's it's quite amusing to me I think we
have a trivial proof a really really
easy proof that gives a tower of height
1 over Epsilon and if we mimic Fox's
technique then we can get a height of
log 1 over Epsilon but here here in this
in the removal image ok so if you spend
if you spend Delta edges in all our
examples you have to remove Delta to the
1 over 100 vertices whereas we get a
tower yeah ok now yeah now we're going
to prove the removal Emma and I want to
say something about what Fox does what
well I'll show also the proof also to
proofs they should take 5 minutes each
so you can see how how easy the first
proof is and so Fox
so Fox's basic idea is is this you you
partition you partition so first you
define some index define index you
partition the graph you look and see
that the graph still has a lot of
triangles then you shatter which means
that you refine the partitions so you
need a good
shattering lemma shattering lemma it's
the same as the proof of the regularity
but yeah and and repeat now there's
something that there yeah Oh Devon I
don't person completely understand yet
plus one small trick that without using
that small trick we we don't have to get
the and the small trick is beginning
with the maximal matching in our case or
in his case beginning with a maximal
this drawing set of triangles so this
small trick which I know maybe that's
small trick was what was missing for 40
years I'll show you the trick it's
really strange it's really elementary
but they somehow without using that
trick we can't go from poly high to log
height and okay how much time do I have
yes I stopped I started at nine or seven
or nine mmm
17 minutes okay so I said we need a good
chattering lemma so now I'm going to
state the vein so what I want to do in
the remaining X minutes is show you the
proof of the removal Emma it's very easy
and as I said you need a good engine you
need a good shattering lemma no that's
perfect so in the first 90 percent of
the time honk you the first half and
okay so what what sorry
what's our engine that's what I said
here we we need the week near far so
here's a a slight a a slight
modification of the original D far but
it's it's implicit in the original paper
so it's good instead of the original D
far I'm going to give you a bipartite
version of this and instead of the
hypothesis being that you start with an
independent set the hypothesis is going
to be that you start with a sparse set
so here's the setting you have two
potatoes I'll explain to you what
potatoes are I I should call them
falafel balls but after collaborating
many years with vital rhodol I adopted
the Eastern European terminology in East
Europe these are things are called
potatoes and no no now these are
potatoes so I have W and W prime which
are in 0 1 2 to the L and what I have
here is just W times 0 1 to the n minus
L and W prime times 0 1 to n minus L so
you just I take L coordinates I fixed
them and then I look at all vectors that
have those that on the first elements
look like W and W prime and this of
course this is an independent set in my
graph remember any two vectors that
share even one coordinate can't have an
edge with and so these are independent
sets and let's assume but that W differs
from W prime in every coordinate so you
do have edges going between these two
and now we have a sphere a set a and
here a set B and my assumptions are that
the size of area the size of B are at
least epsilon over 4 on the size of the
potato
and a a B span few edges and they I
don't want to even say what few is they
spend very few ages and okay so here's a
and here's B and intuitively our
explanation is why they spend few edges
is maybe because in here I took I took
all vectors whose 90s coordinate was 0
and here also I took all vectors whose
90s coordinate was zero and that's why
maybe they don't have any edges at all
so the conclusion is that there are some
new coordinates out of these n minus L
coordinates there's a hunter among these
coordinates which explains what happened
happens so the conclusion is that there
exists I and J so this is I this is J
and I and J almost capture in B so a
minus I and B minus J are less than
let's say even epsilon cubed the size of
a potato and I want inj not to be
trivial so both the size of I and the
size of J are less than so let's let's
call this 1 and this 2 are less than a 1
minus epsilon over 4 of the size of the
potato so I and J aren't everything I
didn't say how many coordinates are in I
and J we're not going to care because
soon we're going to start taking towers
and then but they they're not everything
that's important but furthermore not
only are they not everything one of them
has to be substantially smaller than
everything so either the size of I or
the size of J
is less than 3/4 the size of a potato
okay that's nice shattering lemma
that's so when I have this situation I
can cut this potato into smaller
potatoes and and then I want to iterate
and now I said this is the engine I
should say what what's the fuel inside
the engine which is also the fuel inside
II for it it's it's Moo
so a man over here or there at the
workshop
she's to FIRREA so only ryan is missing
this is Macedo Donald unleash carrots
using the invariance principle it's this
is precisely one of the settings where
it's very useful where you can deduce
that not all influences are small or not
all Fourier coefficients are small so
using mu you can deduce that in such a
setting there's a small Fourier
coefficient which is large which is
precisely what you use to shatter so
this is the fuel inside the engine okay
so now let me show you let me show you
the proof of the room it's it's it's
indexed by few coordinates and it's
large in magnitude or if you prefer a
low Fourier coefficient which is large
okay so let's let me know let me start
with the silly proof of proof which will
give us that Delta which gives us a
tower of height 1 over Epsilon so I have
a sit I'm doing a removal M I'm I'm
showing you that in in our graph if you
have a set that spans fewer edges I can
remove few vertices and make it
independent so I start with the the set
and I take some arbitrary partition into
potatoes and I classify the potatoes
into three types these are the light
potatoes light which means that a in
each of these potatoes are set captures
let's say it most epsilon over four
proportion of the potato okay so we have
our set is these potatoes are vertices
we have a sparse set in these potatoes
the we don't have very many purchases
from ourself forget the light potatoes
now I look at the remaining potatoes and
some of these potatoes have edges
between them but some of them are don't
have any edges going to the other heavy
potatoes and these are independent
independent among the heavy potatoes
so I don't care if there's an edge going
to here because I'm going to throw away
these and remember that every potato
itself is an independent set and so
eventually this is going to be my
independent set and now I have active
potatoes so here are my active potatoes
active potatoes another idea is very
simple
what I want to do is I want to take
these active potatoes I look at I look
at they're two of them now
my hypothesis was that I started with
few edges but I want to assume that I
start with really very very very very
few edges so even after I've iterated
this many times even if all the edges
were between these two potatoes still
that would be few enough edges to apply
my engine so since now you I think those
of you are used to these proofs
understand where the terror comes in
because I have to make sure that few
edges is few even after I partition so
many times in each time I partition this
decreases the size decreases
exponentially so we're going to get at
our number of steps I do so let's look
at let's look at an active potato and so
if it's active I can take find some a
potato if it's not in the independent oh
and then I repeat this and each time
part of the I chop up this potato these
potatoes into smaller potatoes some of
them become light some of them become
independent and some remain active and I
continue this till the proportion of
vertices and active potatoes is let's
say less than epsilon over two and then
I throw away all the active potatoes I
throw away old light potatoes and I've
thrown away very few vertices and I said
so I I throw away all the active
potatoes that's I continue until I had
very few of them I throw away all the
vertices and the light potatoes and even
if all potatoes were light that would
only be throwing away epsilon over four
so I throw away a few vertices and I
remain with
independence it that's yeah it's it's
very yeah what
no no idea no no no okay so though there
are two things here I'll get to you in a
second okay one so firstly this is a
very standard technique it's it's very
simple to immerse first of all in I
didn't show you how I share to this you
do need a good engine to to shatter but
and why so why does this end so when I
take two of these I I cut them into
smaller potatoes and I use one so when I
cut them into smaller potatoes here are
the two potatoes I'm cutting the I and J
miss about at least an epsilon
proportion of of the big potato and the
proportion of the number of vertices
from my set which sit outside I&J is
epsilon cubes so most of these most of
these sub potatoes are alike
so in every step the number of vertices
in active potatoes has to decrease by
let's say multiplicative factor of 1
minus epsilon to the 8th so after a 1
over epsilon steps I have very few
active potatoes and I can stop okay all
right so I I use the fact that they when
I have fewer edges I can partition such
that I capture most of my set
birthday I and J are still missing
missing part of the potato so the parts
that are here are going to be mostly
light so I can take some proportion of
the potato and remove it and move it to
here so yeah this is a very tall do
differ okay so this is this is a really
really easy proof and yeah okay so now
no I said because after because the
number of vertices in inactive potatoes
decreases so after 1 over epsilon steps
the number of vertices an active
potatoes is order of epsilon so you
throw away all that the potatoes throw
away all the vertices and light potatoes
you've only thrown order epsilon vs. is
the way you're left with an independence
right yes so this is exponentially this
introduces new coordinates so for every
potato I introduce a new bunch of
coordinates so the number of potatoes in
the next step is exponential in the
number of potatoes I had enlisted so the
number of potatoes decreases increases
exponentially each step and I had to
make sure that Delta is small even
compared to these very very very very
small no no yeah it's standard by the
way ok I'll save the by the way for the
question ok so yeah no falafel a so now
so that was the power of 1 over epsilon
and now we're going to do the the foxy
proof so foxy proof and this will give
us power
of order love 1 over Epsilon
so if you think this was easy yes such a
easy idea but no no it's it's not easier
but I mean how come it took 40 years to
think of this idea what the idea is now
the proof looks very similar but the
only difference is is we start with a
maximal we have our set and we start
with a start with maximal matching in
the set so I know if you like proofs by
contradiction or not but if your
original set was you have to remove at
least epsilon proportion of the vertices
to become independent then this is true
also if you restrict yourself to this
maximal matching because you have to
remove one vertex from each edge and the
maximal matching so so we know that the
the the size of the matching it has to
be epsilon or two epsilon or something
like that so you begin with a maximum
matching and now I I want to run the
same algorithm as before so I'm doing a
slight modification I define the like
potatoes to be all those where the
weight is less than epsilon over four
but now I want to I always want to work
with the matching so if I thrown away
some vertices I also want to throw away
their their partners so first I throw
away all the vertices in like potatoes
but then those vertices each have
partners so I throw away the partners
also but then a potato may have become
there wasn't like before may become like
now so I continue with this so this
seems like bad news at first but if you
think about it with every light potato
can only contribute twice its its total
weight so this even if you iterate this
the closure of this
only captures epsilon over two a
proportion of the vertices so you throw
away like potatoes and all the partners
in you iterate okay now as before you
have active potatoes and you have
independent potatoes but now I want to
use I want to use this so every active
potato potato a looks for partner B so
you're an active potato means that you
have some edge leaving you so maybe you
have several edges and you look for some
potato which is connected to you and and
hope you hope that in applying now I'm
going to apply this to so here's a
here's B I apply this lemma I find I and
J and one either I or J is less than
three-quarters of the potato and I hope
that in applying to I which contains a
is of size less than three-quarters of
the potato okay
what okay
no I start at 9:07 now it's 956 so I
have another minute okay so so if you if
you find if you find B then you're happy
okay so if I found something B such that
in the shattering the heavy parts
decrease to 3/4 then I'm happy and now
you just note that
unhappy a forum independent set because
if I have to unhappy potatoes if they
were connected by an edge they'd look at
each other and one of them would become
happy by that so the so the happy
potatoes form an independent set and in
a matching every independent set
contains most half of the vertices so at
least half the potatoes are happy ok so
I have these happy potatoes and then
here we have to do what Fox did and find
some potential function it's basically
to the entropy of the I look at the
density of my set in the potato I look
at the average entropy and and now if
you if you've done with regularity
proofs then you're used to this you you
partition it if if I go from such a
situation to and cutting off if all of
this is light then the the entropy will
drop substantially the average entropy
will drop substantially so if I'm
looking at the entropy of the density
and all parts have density 1 was 0 then
then then the entropy is minimal so
every time you you have a partition
where a lot of the parts are almost
empty you increase the entropy
substantially so the idea is that you
define some you define some index and
every time every time you see a pair
like this you can increase the index
substantially and then you that gives
you a better bound on how many times you
can you can't iterate this forever this
is a lot like the proof of the
regularity lemma so that gives you a
better bound on how many times you can
repeat this procedure and that gives you
this log 1 over epsilon times that you
can repeat it and that's it
no the idea was that if you start with a
matching that I mean the key here is
that when when you have such an edge one
of the potatoes that the enthalpy
decreases substantially but you could
have such a situation something that
looks like a star and you apply the
lemma to these two these two these two
these two but on Theon this one is the
one where the entropy increases that's
only a small portion of the potatoes but
using them the matching forces that
passing on the constant proportional
dissipators this is really it's a really
tiny idea but it changes the proof oh I
don't know I don't know how to